I'd hate to see these very talented and  lovely nominees suffer the suspense a  moment longer  those nominated for Best Actress are  Katharine Hepburn in guess who's coming  to dinner and Bancroft in the Graduate  Dame Edith Evans in the whispers Faye  Dunaway in Bonnie and Clyde and Audrey  Hepburn in wait until dark envelope  please cue the winner is Katharine  Hepburn and guess  mr. George Cukor will accept the award  on behalf of Katherine Hepburn  mr. George Cukor accepting for Miss  Hepburn  I know the eyes a friend have a great  great thrill and I'm sure Katherine  thanks you very much and I think it's  very very hard choice you had to make I  anyway I'm sure she'll be very happy  thank you very much